hi I'm Rick Martinez and we are about to
make one of my favorite Salsas from my
book Mi Cosina salsa de tomatillo we're
going to start by grabbing seven medium
sized tomatillos husk rinse and cut next
up grab a medium chili poblano take the
stem out take the seeds out I'm gonna
throw in three four five chili Serranos
take the stem off I'm leaving the seeds
in because I like heat a quarter of a
white onion give them a little choppy
chop now we're going to take your
quarter of an avocado one garlic clove
take the skins off and we're gonna throw
one quarter cup of fresh cilantro leaves
now go grab your blender throw
everything in and three quarters of a
teaspoon of salt we're gonna puree this
on medium low speed because we don't
want to make a smoothie pour that into
your dish and you've got an incredible
salsa that is ready for your chips or
sandwich mmm